Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Team.
Da haben wir jetzt aber eine kleine Pause eingelegt. Äh abgeworfen von unserem.
Durchgehaltenen äh äh Wochenrhythmus, auch wenn das ja der Kongress auch schon mal einen kleinen Streich gespielt hat. Aber äh es gab gute Gründe, du warst im Urlaub.
Ja, ich habe mir äh den Tal hier Platz angeschaut. So, wollte ich mal sehen, wie so ein bisschen Revolution. Und so wollte ich mir angucken.
Und wie sieht's aus?
Ja ist ein größerer Kreisverkehr in Kairo. Kairo hupen sie alle die ganze Zeit.
Ähm und dann ja, dann haben sie da irgendwie das Ding glaube ich und äh ja, ist mein der,
Es ist halt äh ein historischer Ort und hat natürlich den entsprechend das entsprechende Övre, egal was da was da jetzt ist oder nicht, war es natürlich sehr, sehr aufregend, sich diesen Kreisverkehr anzuschauen und ähm.
'ne revolutionstechnisch ist das ja auch alles noch eher Kreisverkehr muss ich eindrucken.
Genau, revolutionstechnisch ist auch ein Kreisverkehr und dann habe ich mir noch das dieses Gebäude angesehen, dass dieses Parteigebäude, was ja unweit des Tahirplatzes, was sie da abgefackelt hatten.
Neben dem ägyptischen Museum. Ja, ganz interessant. Also.
Wie abgefackelt ist das?
Das ist abgefackelt, so dass wir so schnell nicht mehr einziehen.
Das ist äh das Ding ist erledigt. So, ich wir haben uns wir haben noch überlegt, ob die jetzt von dem ägyptischen Museum einfach den Sound um dieses Gebäude erweitern und sagen, hier äh auch ägyptische Geschichte
oder ob sie das jetzt einfach vorkommen lassen, aber ich glaube, im Moment hat das Land noch andere Fragen als sich zu überlegen, wie sie jetzt mit diesem, mit diesem abgefackelten Gebäude umgehen wollen.
Hm. Ja und dann hätten wir ja eigentlich gleich loslegen können. Hat aber nicht geklappt, weil dann äh hat ja die Gesundheit einen Streich gespielt.
Ja, die hat mich mal kurz erwischt.
So und insofern,
Ist das jetzt hier auch so ein bisschen aus dem Krankenbett heraus, aber äh wir scheuen natürlich keine Mühen und äh fühlen uns hier verpflichtet, der Chronik,
Ist ja, ist ja nicht so, dass nichts passiert wäre. Es gab viel äh Acta acta acta an allen Ecken und Enden. Es äh wurde fleißig demonstriert. Äh zweimal mittlerweile.
Gerade jetzt am letzten Wochenende gab's ein weiteren Aufruf den wiederum viele gefolgt sind von daher scheint es gerade kein Mangel an Aktivität zu geben.
Unsere letzte Sendung war ja war ja ein Tag vor dem ersten Aktertag. Wir hatten die letzte Sendung, glaube ich, am zehnten Februar
Und erstmal kam er kurz nach unserem Aufnahmeschluss, die Meldung, Akt Deutschland unterzeichnet Acta vorerst nicht.
Vorerst.
Vorerst und dann war am
elften der europaweite Protesttag, wo man jetzt gar nicht mehr weiß, wie viele hunderttausend Leute überhaupt wo überall äh demonstriert haben. Äh auf jeden Fall war das wirklich eine,
Also ich habe die Berliner Demo gesehen, das war schon
amtliche Ansammlung von Menschen, bei allem, bei alle Verhaltenheit, die wir noch äh in an einem Tag zuvor gezeigt haben, war das, glaube ich, eine sehr,
für mich auf jeden Fall eine sehr große Überraschung. Wie viele Leute da überall in Deutschland in weiß ich nicht wie vielen Ständen demonstriert haben.
Absolut, was für mich noch sehr viel überraschender war äh war wer da kam.
Weil ich einfach nicht so den den Eindruck gewonnen habe, dass das jetzt so das Übliche äh äh Netz politische Gefolge ist, was dort äh aufgetrabt ist, wie man das jetzt auf Freiheit Angst et cetera
normalerweise zu sehen hat, sondern da scheint schon eine junge Generation aus der Höhle gekrochen äh zu sein und hat so ein bisschen den Gamecontroller hier gegen das äh,
Demonstrationsplakat ausgetauscht.
Ja. Also das war, das war äh das war sehr, sehr auffallend, wie jung diese Demo war. Fand ich, äh was ja, was ja gut ist, was ja positiv ist.
Absolut. Absolut. Also ich will ja jetzt noch keinen neuen Trend ausrufen, aber man gewinnt schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass hier ähm,
eine Mobilisierung stattfindet, die na ja zumindest so in der Form bisher noch nicht gesehen wurde und.
Will's nicht überinterpretieren, aber es könnte bedeuten, dass wir jetzt hier wieder an so einem Generationswechsel angekommen sind, wo äh eine.
Gruppe aus der Gesellschaft spricht, für die halt einfach das mit dem Internet jetzt mal so selbstverständlich und so normal ist, dass sie sich einfach in dem.
In dem wofür Akta steht, ja? Unabhängig von dieser immer noch sehr schwierigen Detaildebatte, wo man sich vielleicht an einzelnen Punkten,
abarbeiten könnte, dass sie hier einfach so eine grundsätzliche Bedrohung erkannt wird von dieser Generation, so nach dem Motto,
sag mal, habt ihr sie noch alle? Äh wir haben einfach mal nicht so den Eindruck, dass ihr eigentlich wisst, was das jetzt für uns für eine Bedeutung hat
und äh ja, wir äh finden das nicht gut und wollen uns mal dagegen aussprechen, ist mal so ganz salopp dahin formuliert.
Und ich glaube deswegen hat die hat auf einmal die Politik auch so Schiss bekommen weil ich irgendwie jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Kommen die denn jetzt her, ja.
Ja, wo kommt ihr denn jetzt eigentlich her? Also.
Wer ist er denn? Ja, ja.
Diese ganz normalen äh üblichen Verdächtigen wieder aufgetreten wäre, hätte ich ja nicht so gedacht, so na ja, okay, alles klar, da wird jetzt wieder so ein bisschen demonstriert und äh
wir lassen das mal sein, aber dass sie jetzt schon so einen Tag vorher da den Schwanz eingezogen haben, gesagt haben, wir unterschreiben das jetzt erstmal nicht. Da war ich dann doch schon ein bisschen überrascht,
Wie's dir ging, aber das hätte ich jetzt so nicht erwartet.
Hatte ich auch nicht mit gerechnet. Ähm es ging ja dann noch weiter, ja, Bulgarien und Niederlande haben dann noch weiter
abgelehnt und dann hat die EU-Kommission ja ihre Rückzugsstrategie,
begonnen zu diskutieren. Dann starteten irgendwann auch noch campact und digitale Gesellschaft so eine Kampagne. Da gibt's jetzt, glaube ich, auch bald siebzigtausend Leute, die da irgendwie unterzeichnet haben.
Und jetzt ist der.
Zweite Protesttag liegt ja gerade hinter uns. Ähm der war am fünfundzwanzigsten Februar. Da waren es selbstverständlich weniger Menschen.
Aber es gab da auch einige strategische äh Überlegungen, diesen Protest irgendwie zu dezentralisieren und so, aber immer noch viele tausend Menschen und in vielen verschiedenen Städten. Ähm es gab da, glaube ich, insgesamt für beide Demos, gab es
eines bei den Stop-Acta-Protest,
stop acta minus Protest Punkt Info, bei denen im Wiki haben sie die Teilnehmerzahlen aus den Städten, da ist allein schon die Anzahl der Städte äh relativ,
überwältigend. Auf jeden Fall äh der Status quo für uns jetzt am heutigen Tage ist, dass die.
Bundesregierung, das vorerst der Bundesregierung so zu interpretieren ist, dass sie sagt, sie will frühestens nach einer Entscheidung im Europaparlament unterschreiben.
Und die Europakommission im Rahmen ihrer Rückzugsstrategie hat den Akterentwurf jetzt erstmal dem Europäischen Gerichtshof zur Prüfung vorgelegt und der soll nämlich prüfen nach Artikel achtundzwanzig
ob der, ob dieser ACTA Staatsvertrag mit dem,
mit dem mit den EU Verträgen kompatibel ist, die also die Verträge, die die EU statt.
Konstatuieren oder wie man was das Verb an dieser, das korrekte Verb an dieser Stelle ist. Und erst konstituieren. Und ähm wenn dann,
dass der Europäische Gerichtshof gesagt hat, ja, das ist in Ordnung oder nicht
würde das Europa, will das Europaparlament entscheiden. Also erst äh entscheidet jetzt der EUGH, dann entscheidet das Europaparlament, dann entscheidet Deutschland. Und das kann eigentlich anderthalb bis zwei Jahre dauern.
Jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, warum hat die Europakommission dieses Frage zur Prüfung an den Europäischen Gerichtshof gegeben.
Warum erst jetzt?
Genau und warum er warum erst jetzt, warum zu diesem Zeitpunkt? Und da hatte Markus bei Netzpolitik auch so ein bisschen die ähm.
Theorie entfaltet, dass sich das durchaus um eine Inhaltetaktik handeln könnte. Dass sie also sagen,
Na okay, damit gewinnen wir erstmal Zeit. Und zweitens ist der, ist ActA sowieso so vage formuliert, dass es dem EUGH schwerfallen wird, da einen konkreten Verstoß tatsächlich.
Zu finden, sodass die Wahrscheinlichkeit durchaus da ist, dass der Europäische Gerichtshof keine großartigen, also nichts, nichts äh handfestes finden kann,
um dieses Akteabkommen abzulehnen.
Und ähm dann wäre es natürlich so, dann würden sie von mir aus in anderthalb Jahren oder zwei Jahren wieder äh ins Europaparlament gehen und ihr Akter hätte quasi das Prüfsiegel vom Europäischen Gerichtshof abgesegnet.
Das wäre natürlich dann so strategisch äh dann sehr gelungen von der Europakommission.
Ne, wobei das natürlich so ein bisschen der klassische Ansatz ist. Ich bin mir aber nicht so sicher, ob die gleiche Diskussion in zwei Jahren äh wirklich verpufft ist oder ob bis dahin nicht äh äh
erstens die Generation noch weiter nachgerüstet hat und äh wir auch netzpolitisch mittlerweile die ganze Debatte auf dem ganz anderen Level führen. Also.
Sicher, dass sich.
Also tatsächliche Zweifel werden natürlich auch als als mögliche Begründung angeführt und ähm,
Selbst wenn jetzt dieser EUGH Stempel da draufkleben würde, wovon ja erstmal, was ja absolut hypothetisch ist, selbst dann kann ja das EU-Parlament immer noch sagen, na ja äh,
den Protesten ist mir völlig egal, was da für ein Stempel drauf ist, ganz offensichtlich wollen die Leute das nicht.
Also es ist noch alles offen. Ja, es äh ist jetzt erstmal auf jeden Fall liegt's jetzt auf der
auf der langen Bank. Und aber diese Frage der Prüfung äh im EUGH, die wird nämlich ganz interessant, weil Meinungs- und Redefreiheit einmal im Grundrecht ist, laut EU-Vertrag geistiges Eigentum aber auch.
Und die müssen jetzt quasi äh also haben auf jeden Fall mal eine relativ interessante ähm Fragestellung, die sie da irgendwie abwägen müssen. Was, was vielleicht das höhere Grundrecht ist oder was auch immer. Ich meine, äh.
Wie gesagt, im Moment weiß man nichts Genaues,
Und es bleibt bleibt bleibt spannend und äh eine Unterzeichnung Aktas innerhalb des nächsten Jahres ist auf jeden Fall erstmal unwahrscheinlich viel schöner wäre es aber natürlich trotzdem, wenn man sich den ganzen Schmuhren könnte und äh Ding einfach jetzt beerdigt wird.
Hm
Ja, ist ganz interessant. Ich meine, hier könnte sich unter Umständen auch rächen, dass äh bei Acta der Bogen so weit gespannt wurde, dass er also von Urheberrecht bis äh äh so Meinungsfreiheit an sich so viele Bereiche tangiert werden.
Ja, das.
Habe ich Schwierigkeiten da, mangels juristische Ausbildung, dass äh diese Dimension einzuschätzen, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass also gerade auch diese Vermischung so vieler Themen an der Stelle äh entweder die Prüfung ewig hinauszögert oder eben auch genau deshalb ähm zu so einem Schluss kommt, so nach dem Motto, äh das ist hier einfach alles unvereinbar, weil äh der Bogen viel zu weit gespannt wurde
ne? Weißt du denn, ob da auch jetzt generell diese Fragestellung der
geheim Aushandlung, die ja in der Debatte auch immer eine große Rolle spielt in irgendeiner Form mit äh in den Topf geworfen wird.
Nö, das hat den äh EU GH nicht äh das in tangiert ja nicht großartig. Also die interessiert dann der Text des Abkommens und fertig.
Und was jetzt da die Erweiterung davon sind, ob der die tatsächlich auch prüfen wird. Ähm
wir sehen, habe ich aber jetzt so erstmal nicht verstanden. Es gibt eine sehr interessante Zusammenfassung von äh Etri dot org, European Digital Rights. Das ist also so eine,
ähm ja, wie könnte man die am besten bezeichnen? Also eine eine Lobby-Organisation führt digitale Bürgerrechte auf EU-Ebene.
Die haben da eine sehr schöne FAQ zusammengestellt und äh die Leute, die sitzen also tatsächlich direkt in Brüssel und setzen sich
genau mit diesem Thema auseinander. Und selbst die sagen also, es ist im Moment echt unklar, was was da jetzt was auf was aus der Sache jetzt genau wird,
Was die aber auch äh wovor Edri warnt, ist, dass ja auf EU-Ebene das,
äh auch diskutiert werden soll, die irgendwie fürn Sommer geplant ist in der EU. Das ist quasi so eine Art Mini-Akter,
für die EU, also als als EU-Ebene, wie wie wir ja so mehrere Richtlinien haben.
Im Direktiven haben, in der EU, was wie mit bestimmten Dingen umzugehen ist, beispielsweise auch einer Vorratsdatensprechung. Ähm.
Und da wollen sie also auch eine für das geistige Eigentum haben. Das wäre so eine weitere, also eine weitere.
These, die auch aus dem Umfeld von Edri mal zitiert wurde, ist, dass ähm,
man jetzt quasi um das IPred Angst hat und sagt, komm, lass uns lieber mal unsere
intellektual propoty Rides in Forcement Direct vier schnell durch äh bringen und das so ein bisschen
die Befürchtung steht, dass jetzt der Akta-Protest genau direkt darauf rüberschwappt, dass also der der Acta-Mop der der undemokratische Aktermob, wie ihr ja von den von den Interessenvertretern genannt wurde, ähm.
Dass der sich jetzt dann direkt das nächste Opfer sucht und auch noch gegen die äh aufbegehrt.
Könnte sehr gut sein, dass äh diese ganzen ähm ETLAs und E zwei TLAs, die jetzt hier so alle auf den Tisch kommen, dann einfach nur äh sich auf äh addieren und alle irgendwie gefährdet sind. Ich will das jetzt nicht zu positiv
darstellen, aber mir scheint's jetzt gerade so, als
schwingt da einfach das Pendel äh auf der Straße in eine interessante äh Geschichte. Wir nennen, wir haben es ja ganz am Anfang noch sehr gewundert, so
Polen, Fragezeichen, ja wieso jetzt ausgerechnet Polen,
bei ähm Holland wundert mich auch jetzt grad noch, aber auch in den Kommentaren wurde natürlich nicht ganz so unrecht darauf hingewiesen, dass in Osteuropa.
Natürlich ähm auch so dieses gefährdete Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung
nochmal eine besondere Rolle spielt. Ich meine, in Deutschland sitzen wir hier relativ so äh äh im im Speck und uns äh ging's immer gut so relativ, ja, klar. Ähm da gibt's dann so eine
kleine Gruppe von Leuten, die natürlich immer der Meinung war, das könnte einerseits alles noch viel besser sein, sei eben auch gefährdet,
teilt natürlich die Öffentlichkeit nicht in dem selben Maße. Das ist ja so ein so ein so ein so ein fortwährender Kampf, der die ganze Debatte in den letzten Jahren auch immer mitgeprägt hat
aber in Osteuropa mögen da einfach die Wunden noch offener
liegen, ja? Da ist einfach die Revolution noch nicht so lange her, da war einfach die Meinungs äh äh Freiheit vor zwanzig Jahren noch äh in einem ganz anderen Zustand oder dreiundzwanzig Jahre muss man mittlerweile sagen,
Das äh rückt ja auch immer alles weiter nach hinten, aber die junge Generation hat das einfach noch ganz anders
vor dem Auge und auch das mag dort 'ne Rolle spielen und das mag jetzt auch 'ne Erklärung sein warum in Tschechien, warum in Polen und eben auch in Bulgarien.
Ähm dass eben da viel heißer diskutiert wird. Und von daher ja,
vielleicht eben auch erst am Anfang in dieser ganzen Debatte und kriegt auch die europäische Dimension hier nochmal eine ganz andere ähm.
Einen ganz anderen Spin, weil bisher waren wir eigentlich immer so ein bisschen gewohnt, dass so äh
Osteuropa, ne, dass das am Anfang waren sie alle immer so in diesem äh Jahr Aufbruch und äh äh wir müssen unsere Wirtschaft äh äh voranbringen et cetera und da wurde dann links und rechts nicht so sehr auf die Details äh geachtet
dass er sich jetzt vielleicht grade umdreht und wir eben die größere Skepsis tatsächlich jetzt hier äh auch ernten und ähm auf einmal auch nur Unterstützung in der ganzen Debatte bekommen, wo man sie so erstmal gar nicht vermutet hat.
Also es gibt äh wie immer eine sehr ausführliche Linkssammlung von meiner Seite dazu, ganz viel Spannendes noch zu lesen, zu Akta.
Wer sich da noch weiter mit.
Möchte. Wer nicht genug von Acta kriegen kann, ja, nachdem wir es so lange so sträflich versäumt haben, ist jetzt, glaube ich, auch insbesondere Netzpolitik org voll mit Acta, das jetzt schon wieder in die Kommentare kommt. Geht's nichts anderes mehr als Akte. Doch gibt es.
Gibt es. Was gibt's denn noch äh anderes als äh Acta?
Den Datenschutz bei Mobile Apps, nicht mobile Max, sondern mobile Apps. Äh das ging damit los, dass der,
dass es Social Network paff. Ich ich bin ja nicht so der Social Networker,
Nicht so der Social Network-User zumindest. Äh äh hat also sich irgendwie als datenschutzfreundliche Facebook-Alternative äh
hervor getan und insbesondere so betont, dass es irgendwie auf dem auf dem mobilen Endgerät als als primäres
primäre primäres Device laufen will und stellte sich heraus, hat dann mal jemand irgendwie dieses angemacht und mit einem mal reingehört, was das denn so womit das so kommuniziert
und ähm stellte sich raus, dieses überträgt das gesamte Adressbuch
des Nutzers an den Server des Betreibers. Also man gibt sein komplettes iPhone Adressfo.
Und natürlich ähm fragt die App vorher nicht und äh das kocht also sehr schnell sehr hoch
und ähm dann hat sich dann irgendwie, weiß ich, ein paar Tage später haben sie sich dann entschuldigt, haben gesagt, ja, tut uns leid. Ähm wir löschen diese komplette Datenbank und machen das jetzt auch nicht mehr. Wir haben eine Update unserer Software
hochgeladen und dann kam aber so dieser.
Moment, sie sagen schon, also die Funktionalität ist schon noch drin, nur fragen sie einen jetzt vorher.
Ah, genau, genau, jetzt, also sie haben's gelöscht und haben ein, genau, sie haben jetzt, also sie haben alle bisherigen Daten gelöscht
und haben jetzt eine in der geupdateten Software wird vorher gefragt, wie das zum Beispiel auch äh andere Dienste machen, beispielsweise.
Ähm WhatsApp.
Macht das, glaube ich, auch. Und aber dann ging's nämlich los, dann fiel quasi ein bunter Reigen äh.
Irgendwie übers Internet herein, wo dann irgendwie Twitter äh wenn man,
bei der Installation der Twitter-App auf dem iPhone, also für diejenigen, die nicht irgendwie eine andere App nutzen, äh wenn man bei der Twitter-App sagt, durchsuche deine Kontakte.
Dann heißt das äh lade mal mein Adressbuch bei Twitter hoch, wo es dann für achtzehn Monate gespeichert wird. Auch das war jetzt irgendwie nicht unbedingt so klar.
Ähm da gibt's übrigens auch bei uns in den Links dann
äh den Link dazu, wie man diese Daten bei Twitter auch wieder löschen kann. Äh Forsquare hat wohl auch nicht ausreichend gewarnt, wenn wenn man sein Adressbuch an sie geschickt hat und eine App namens Foodspotting, die ich aber nicht kenne
Problem, was sich da einfach zeigte, war das eine die App-Store-Richtlinie von Apple nicht verlangt, äh dass man davor warnt, wenn man dieses Adressbuch absaugt.
Und auf den Server schickt. Das wäre jetzt, weil unabhängig von diesen großen Apps, die da
äh groß irgendwie das das Medieninteresse hatten. Ähm wäre das natürlich auch eine interessante Einnahmequelle bei gratis Apps, um irgendwie äh Spam-E-Mail-Adressen zu sammeln, ne. Machst du irgendwie die hundertste.
Dein iPhone ist ein Bier, was du trinken kannst, App und sammelst einfach mal ein paar vernünftige, aktive E-Mail-Adressen, die du dann irgendwie im Bündel an Sperma verkaufen kannst oder so
Äh das wäre jetzt aber das jetzt wirklich nur so meine mein theoretische Anwendungsfall ist nicht bekannt, dass das jemand tatsächlich gemacht hätte
Aber dieses ganze Thema ist dann im Twitter und alle betroffen waren, äh,
schrieb dann irgendwie erstmal so einen Kongressabgeordneter, einen Brief an Tim Cook, den CEO von Apple und dann kam die äh,
äh die Staatsanwältin und traf dann innerhalb weniger Tage eine Vereinbarung mit Apple, Google, Microsoft AIM, das ist sind die Blackberry Hersteller, Judith Packert und Amazon.
Ähm dass sie also in Zukunft den Datenschutz bei ihren Mobile Apps stärken müssen und.
Apple kündigte dann an, dass in der nächsten iOS-Version der Adressbuch Zugriff genauso geregelt sein soll wie der Zugriff auf die Locations.
Kannst ja ähm bei bei einer aktuellen Eiweiß-Version sagen, welcher Dienst darf äh meine Location überhaupt erfahren und welcher nicht? Also.
Unabhängig davon wofür sie nutzen will, kommt also ein Fenster wo dann steht hier.
Was weiß ich, Twitter möchte wissen, wo du bist, darf Twitter das überhaupt erfahren auf Betriebssystemebene. Und das wollen sie jetzt auch für den Adressbuch Zugriff machen.
Ja, das wird sich zeigen, ob das ähm solche Auswirkungen hat. Ich meine, die die ganze Geschichte war noch insofern äh interessant. Es gab ja früher schon auch Apps und ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht mehr ganz so sicher, aber ich glaube, das war sogar WhatsApp.
Ja, die halt irgendwie gefragt haben, ja, die sozusagen jetzt.
In der aktuellen Sichtweise richtig getan haben, haben aber dafür quasi einen dicken Einlauf von ihren Usern bekommen, so nach dem Motto, oh Gott, was was tut ihr da? Ähm ja und danach.
Fühlten sich wahrscheinlich auch einige äh ermutigt, da gar nicht erst groß äh das Maul aufzureißen, weil sie da quasi den Shitstorm ähm.
Lieber nicht haben wollen.
Nicht haben wollten, ja? Und.
Ich finde jetzt auch, dass diese, wenn man's auch beim schon mal in der letzten Sendung ausführlich diskutiert.
Das Problem ist, ein Zugriff auf das Adressebuch ist halt aus vielen Gründen.
Nachvollziehbar, ja?
Das bedeutet ja nicht unbedingt, dass der Zugriff auf das Adressbuch durch das Programm auch automatisch bedeutet, dass die Daten übertragen werden irgendwohin. Ja, also es sind ja wirklich zwei vollständig unterschiedliche Dinge und in gewisser Hinsicht kann Apple
technisch dieses Ich übertrage, mal den Inhalt des Adressbuchs irgendwo hin, gar nicht verhindern. Also es ist.
Technisch, also wenn man das wollen würde und wenn man darüber nachdenken würde, wie man das technisch verhindern kann, dann glaube ich nicht, dass da irgendwas brauchbares bei rauskommt. Die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu verhindern
ist in gewisser Hinsicht, dass die Programme eben dieses auch explizit sagen müssen gegenüber dem Upstor Review-Prozess.
Und ähm ich bin ja jetzt habe da jetzt grad so eine kleine Erinnerungslücke, aber meiner Meinung nach war das sowieso schon drin.
Das heißt, wenn du sowas tun wollen würdest, dann war's eh gezwungen, das Apple mitzuteilen, aber das haben sie wohl dann wiederum alle nicht getan oder Apple hat es nicht ausreichend überprüft oder sich nicht äh entsprechend drum gekümmert, da da eier ich jetzt grad ein wenig
unabhängig davon bleibt natürlich das Problem.
Ähm wie kann man da äh das wünschenswerte von dem weniger wünschenswerten Trend. Ja, das ist ein klassisches Datenschutz äh Dilemma.
Natürlich möchte ich, dass das Programm äh die Daten in dem Adressbuch nutzt, um was weiß ich, Telefonnummern in Namen aufzulösen, damit es halt einfach,
Ja, dass dass einfach das Benutzen einfacher ist.
Möchte aber jetzt nicht, dass Daten abgegriffen werden und irgendwo gespeichert werden, ohne dass ich gefragt werde, vor allem welche, die überhaupt nicht relevant sind.
Ich denke, die Programme haben sich da an der Stelle auch ähm viel zu einfach gemacht,
Ist ja auch gar nicht unbedingt erforderlich, um äh dass alle Daten übertragen werden, um das zu bekommen, was sie äh da tatsächlich machen möchten, weil der Hintergrund ist natürlich bei diesen sozialen Netzwerken, die möchten natürlich,
irgendwie es dir einfach machen oder es auch sich einfach machen. Das ist äh ja, dass das bleibt dann noch zu debattieren, wie man das dann letzten Endes sieht
Ja, aber ich habe ja so eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung. Angenommen, ich bin jetzt so ein aktiver, also mir geht's ja da genauso wie dir. Ich nutze das auch nicht so aktiv. Ich habe auch so einen äh Account bei Pars und für mich ist es wie bei den meisten sozialen Netzwerken, ich frage mich dann immer so
was.
Mir das jetzt eigentlich wirklich jo, ja. Ich will jetzt nicht im dreißigsten Dienst auch wieder irgendwo sehen, wo die Leute sich gerade ein Brötchen gekauft haben und äh irgendwelche alten Züge fotografiert haben, aber das sei ja jetzt äh jedem unbenommen.
Er möchte also gerne,
mir ein funktionierendes soziales Netzwerk vorschlagen, was im Idealfall eben auf meinem bisherigen sozialen Netzwerk basiert. Und da bietet sich natürlich das Adressbuch an, auch wenn es nicht bedeutet, dass jeder, der da drin ist, äh automatisch mein Freund ist oder so.
Ich habe auch Leute explizit deshalb im Adressbuch, weil sie eben nicht meine Freunde sind.
Sie nicht deine Freunde sind.
Irgendwie Telefonnummern, äh E-Mail-Adressen entsprechend auch äh erkenne und sofort weiß, wer dahinter steckt, um dann mein Verhalten entsprechend anzupassen. Das ist schon mal das.
Die Leute, die unter Achtung im Telefonbuch gespeichert sind, damit groß im Display steht, Achtung, Arschloch ruft an, nicht dran gehen. Oder äh wie muss ich mir das vorstellen? Also da gibt der Tim keine Aussagen, keine äh keine Auskünfte zu.
Was auch immer. Ich meine, äh das hat jeder äh es gibt ja auch so Sachen, es gibt halt strukturierte und unstrukturierte Informationen. Ja, es gibt so äh die E-Mail-Adresse, die Telefonnummer, da ist halt irgendwie ganz klar, wie die Zuordnung ist. Aber es gibt ja auch Notizen
in so einem Adressbuch mit drin stehen, die es einfach mal ja mit den Paars so überhaupt gar nichts anfangen kann. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die das.
Übertragen haben, ja? Ähm weiß auch gar nicht, ob's da irgendwie eine klare Aussage dazu gibt, was sie jetzt eigentlich genommen haben oder nicht.
Weil, was brauchen sie denn schon groß? Sie brauchen
vielleicht eigentlich nur, na ja, Telefonnummern könnten ihnen dabei helfen, das zuzuordnen, E-Mail-Adressen sind immer ein äh interessanter Bereich, weil die ja meistens auch angegeben werden. Der Name spielt natürlich eine Rolle. Am Ende gibt es eben,
Keine klare Zuordnung, weil was weiß ich, Michael Müller äh kann in jedem Netzwerk eine andere E-Mail-Adresse verwenden, äh gibt nicht unbedingt deine Telefonnummer an, ja? Äh das mag helfen, es mag nicht helfen
Aber die eigentliche Frage ist halt
ist es denn überhaupt erforderlich sowas zu übertragen? Weil man kann ja hier auch mit arbeiten ja und die dann in entsprechend übertragen und das vergleichen. Irgendjemand hat dann diesen Vorschlag gemacht und dann meinte dann auch jemand von Paar so och, ist ja mal eine tolle Idee und so. Da denken wir mal drüber nach. Weißt du, Leute.
Also es gibt ja, es gibt ja äh zwei zwei Probleme hier. Einmal ähm du hast jetzt sehr viel von dir selber gesprochen.
Ähm.
Wenn wir jetzt mal uns überlegen, dass du meine Telefonnummer an paff gegeben hast, weil ich weiß, ich bin in deinem Adressbuch. Ähm da ist natürlich dann dieser dieser Aspekt, der nämlich auch schon bei dem Freundefinder von Facebook
damals das große Thema war, als Facebook nämlich auch seine Nutzer irgendwie sagte, er ja und jetzt gib doch mal noch ganz schnell hier dein
Gmail-Passwort ein, dann können wir mal eben deine Freunde einladen und die haben dann die das Adressb,
was da bei Google gespeichert ist, abgesaugt und sonst was. Äh also das Problem dabei ist ja, dass das quasi jemand, der keinerlei Beziehungen zu diesem
Anbieter hat, der vielleicht noch nicht einmal weiß, dass es ihn gibt
äh bei dem in der Datenbank landet. Und äh bei mir war es dann zum Beispiel so, ich war, wie gesagt, nie bei Facebook und habe dann immer,
ähm diese E-Mails bekommen irgendwie was weiß ich, Person, X, Y ist jetzt bei Facebook ähm,
und du bist ja mit der befreundet, guck doch mal ob du nicht auch zu Facebook kommen willst und übrigens hier sind noch ein paar andere Leute die,
kennst du bestimmt auch und die sind auch bei Facebook und da war dann so 'ne Liste von zwanzig Leuten die kannte ich alle.
Die haben haben im Zweifelsfall äh auch meine meine Adresse da hochgeladen oder was auch immer. Das heißt, nicht nur hatte Facebook in dem Fall meine
E-Mail-Adresse und meinen Namen, sondern die wussten auch schon mit wem ich bekannt beziehungsweise befreundet bin. Und das ist das,
ist ja dann die große datenschutzrechtliche Auseinandersetzung wo dann,
wo man dann sagen kann, ja, also die bauen offensichtlich ein Profil über mich, obwohl ich
noch nie irgendeine Datenschutzvereinbarung, bei denen unterschrieben habe oder sonst was. Und da muss man natürlich irgendwie eine Möglichkeit des Umgangs mit finden. Es gibt dann, sage ich mal, einige, die sagen, ja, ähm.
Ich glaube, das bei Niko Loma hat dich das letzte Mal gelesen. Er hat da teilweise relativ einfache,
Argumentationen zu der dann sagt, ja diese Dienste bescheren mir so viele Besucher auf meinem Blog, dann kann ich ruhig die alle denen alle Daten liefern von meinen Leuten oder was auch immer. Ähm
Die andere Möglichkeit ist zu sagen, okay, dann versuchen wir abzuwägen, wie viele Daten brauchen die oder welche Daten brauchen die tatsächlich
also jetzt bei diesem Past zum Beispiel, dann sollen die halt nur nach der Mobilfunknummer gehen. Ja gut, also gucken die in dem Visitenkarteneintrag nach ähm.
Mobile Rufnummer und ich weiß nicht, wie du dein Adressbuch schlägst, aber ich weiß, dass die meisten irgendwie nicht darauf achten, ob die Nummer, die sie da jetzt einspeichern, auch korrekt unter
als iPhone, Mobile oder privat oder geschäftlich getagt ist, sondern die Nummer kommt einfach da rein, dass die Telefonnummer,
Also das heißt, an diesen Meter Informationen kann man sich dann da schwer orientieren, wenn man sagt, man möchte einschränken. Notizen,
Klar ist ein Feld, was was die jetzt echt nicht zu interessieren hätte. Aber allein, wenn man nur mal sagt, die sollen nur mal gucken, welche Telefonnummern richten sich irgendwie nach der Telefonnummer wie WhatsApp zum Beispiel?
Ja welche sollen die denn dann nehmen? Also bei mir äh
mein eigener Visitenkarteneintrag in meinem iPhone, beinhaltet vier, fünf Telefonnummern und unter denen ich erreichbar bin, weil woher weiß also da geht's ja schon los. Und wenn ich jetzt dann irgendwo hochgeladen werde.
Woher soll dann WhatsApp wissen, ähm bei bei Themen nehme ich die Telefonnummer und nicht die. Also schicken sie alle, klar.
Ja, es ist äh ganz viele Fragestellungen äh stellen sich da, ne. Was ich vorhin noch äh
angedeutet hatten, nicht ganz zu Ende äh geführt habe. Das spielt ja hier auch noch mit rein. Also es sind ja nicht nur die Telefonnummern. Was ist mit den anderen Sachen, ja? Was jetzt diese Auflagen an Apple und die anderen äh Hersteller betrifft, ist heißt Adressbuch Zugriff, Zugriff auf alles
Ja? Oder kann ich sagen, hier Notizen zum Beispiel kriegt einfach generell einfach
keiner, ja, das steht nur, wenn da das Adressbuchprogramm und wenn ein Programm kommt, was sagt, okay, ich mache dir das Verwalten des Adressbuchs einfach, ja. Ich zeige dir hier äh diese Inhalte. Okay, dann kann ich sagen
der darf auch das und das haben, aber die anderen dürfen eben nur ein haben. Das wäre sagen wir mal zumindest so ein ganz grober Ansatz. Macht natürlich dann aber auch wiederum,
das Zuweisen von Zugriffsrechten et cetera unter Umständen zu einem Alptraum, womit die Leute sich eben auch nicht rumschlagen wollen,
andere Sachen, die mir gerade noch eingefallen ist, mit deinem Beispiel mit ich sende ja auch die Daten anderer Leute in dem Moment, müsste man sich nicht vielleicht auch fragen, ob es nicht nur eine Datenschutzfrage ist für.
Betriebssystemanbieter unserer Party-Apps. Ist es nicht sogar so, dass man darüber nachdenken könnte, dass es mir verboten sein könnte, diese Daten überhaupt,
zu liefern, ja? Stellt sich hier die Datenschutzfrage nicht genau in der anderen Richtung, dass ich das gar nicht darf.
Ja, kommt drauf an, wie du an die Telefonnummer gekommen bist.
Ich habe auch ein paar Telefonnummern, die habe ich illegal.
Deine Telefonnummer, einer einem anderen Betriebssystem, einem Dienstleister, einer Cloud, was auch immer, äh zu übermitteln, ja. Kommt nicht da jetzt nicht für äh in in Knast. Müsste man nicht irgendwie alle,
Facebook präventiv alle einsperren, weil sie mal äh auf Freigabe geklickt haben.
Diese ganzen Nummern, die wir von den Leuten bekommen, die die eindeutig maschinell verarbeiten, ne?
Ja.
Und ein Dritte geben.
Genau, also es ist.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Alles, alles nicht schön.
Was ich an diesem, an diesem Ablauf, den wir da jetzt gerade so besprochen haben, sehr spannend fand, ist, dass ähm.
Wie das also sage ich mal, diese Datenschutzfrage in den USA so schnell so hochgekocht und so schnell mit einem äh mit einem bisschen ähm ja.
Mit ein bisschen Schlangenöl von höchster Ebene dann versehen wurde, ne? Also sofort irgendwie da und sofort alle äh Firmen an den Tisch und das abgesprochen. Könnte man natürlich auch über.
Äh irgendwie Theo sich vorstellen, dass das damit zu tun hat, dass es da viel weniger äh das Interesse der Staatsanwaltschaft war, sondern vielmehr das Interesse der Firmen sich auch da möglichst schnell ein spannendes Siegel zu holen und in dem Fall eben eine
eine eine Roundtable mit mit dem mit dem mit der Staatsanwaltschaft
und eine Vereinbarung und eine Selbstverpflichtung innerhalb kürzester Zeit herzuführen, bevor da die Debatte weitergeführt.
Auf jeden Fall. Also das da finde ich auch mehrere Punkte interessant. Einmal was du sagst. Die Firmen haben selber ein Interesse dadran, ja? Ist ja auch so äh Apple und andere haben sich ja auch schon zusammengetan und äh möchten gerne,
Hätten eigentlich gerne mehr Privatsphärenauflagen für ihre Cloud-Dienste? Weil sie natürlich ein Problem darin sehen
dass äh die allgemeine Wahrnehmung, die wahrscheinlich auch absolut berechtigt ist, äh da ist so, A, wenn ich jetzt was in der Cloud abspeichere, dann kann die CIA, FBI, wer auch immer da jederzeit mal vorbeikommen, keinem muss was gesagt werden, wie wir das bei Twitter und WikiLeaks äh Daten schon hatten, wo es mal ausnahmsweise mal sichtbar gewesen ist
die sehen einfach die Felle davonschwimmen,
Auf der einen Seite, der Trend geht zur Cloud, alle Leute wollen das, weil es ja so schön einfach ist, weil man eben Dinge da auf einmal tun kann, die einen immer äh genervt haben, dass sie vorher nicht da waren, nicht wahr? Synchronisation von Daten, das ist ja auch etwas, was man gerne hätte
ja? Nur, dass die Abwägung in dem Moment immer im Raum steht, so, oh Gott, wenn ich das jetzt hier mache und alles liegt auf iCloud, äh dann dann liege ich einfach nackt
äh äh im im Internet und äh alles läuft gegen mich, ja?
Muss nur noch einer herausfinden, wie meine Katze heißt und der hat mich in der Hand.
Na ja, es ist es ist halt sehr leicht möglich und das fangen die Leute an, an zu begreifen und interessanterweise eben auch
auf einmal in den USA, wo wir ja noch vor gar nicht so langer Zeit das Gefühl hatten, die
sind nicht in der Lage, das Wort Datenschutz auch nur zu buchstabieren. Ja, das, das, das, das, die würden nicht auch nur im Traum auf die Idee kommen. Und äh jetzt auf einmal
Gibt's so ein kleines Skandalchen und schwuppdiwupp sind irgendwie alle an einem Tisch und äh die Interessen sind auf einmal ganz anders verteilt. Die Politik entdeckt
Thema. Die äh großen Anbieter äh wollen auf einmal äh gerne sogar auch ein bisschen reguliert werden, je nachdem wie ihr äh Businessmodell ist, ja? Facebook vielleicht eher nicht so sehr, weil,
sie leben auch von diesen Daten ein Stück weit. Apple.
Würde sich, glaube ich, da eher regulieren lassen wollen, weil ihr Businessmodell ist ist ein anderes. Sie verkaufen äh Geräte und sie verkaufen eben mit diese Dienstleistung und möchten gerne
dass alle Leute den Eindruck haben, also mindestens den Eindruck, vielleicht sogar auch die Gewissheit haben,
äh in gewisser Hinsicht für sie mit rechten Dingen zugeht. Also die Sache kommt auf jeden Fall enorm in Bewegung.
Bin ich sehr gespannt. Wir bleiben beim Datenschutz.
Bleiben wir das.
Ja, nämlich beim Bericht des Bundesbeauftragten für den Datenschutz und die Informationsfreiheit,
über, wo man hier den ganzen über den Staatstrojaner, ja, den gesamten Bericht des Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten über Maßnahmen der
Quellen, Telekommunikationsüberwachung bei den Sicherheitsbehörden des Bundes. So war glaube ich der Gesamtttitel. Äh und zwar hat der Peter Schar
bis Ende Januar wohl an einem Datenschutzbericht zum Staatstrojaner gewirkt.
Und den dann abgeschlossen und der ist jetzt irgendwie aufgetaucht. Ähm obwohl er eigentlich als Verschlusssache gekennzeichnet war und äh da kommen so allerlei interessante,
Funde zu Tage, nämlich dass das Bundeskriminalamt und äh das Zeugkriminalamt ebenfalls äh Kunden bei Digitals sind ähm für das BKA existiert da einen Rahmenvertrag, digitals, wie gesagt, die,
Softwareschmiede, die den Staatstrojaner bereitgestellt hat.
Äh es hatte keine der Bundesbehörden Zugang zum zum Quellcode dieses, die dieses Programmes. Ähm wir erinnern's uns an diesen Skandal um den Staatstrianer, den der CCC damals dann entdeckt hatte. Äh das BKA hat sich,
darüber hinaus dann noch geweigert, äh überhaupt dem Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten auch nur den Binärcode äh zur Einsicht zu überlassen. Ähm.
Teilweise haben sie dann auch direkt das ganze Ausspiel spionieren komplett an Digitask ausgelagert. Das heißt, ähm.
Die vollständige Ermittlung wurde als Auftrag an eine private Firma vergeben. Das würde ich mal als nochmal mittelschweren Skandal obendrauf bezeichnen.
Und dann hat er auch irgendwie gefunden, dass in zumindest einem Fall äh Liebesbeteuerung und Selbstbefriedigungshandlungen dokumentiert wurden
also genau dieser Teil, der bei solchen Abhörmaßnahmen äh wo dann die
Mikrofone ausgeschaltet werden müssen oder die Ermittler wenigstens so schlau sein müssen, wenn sie Mikrofone schon nicht ausschalten, dann wenigstens nicht noch mitzuschreiben.
Handelt es sich dabei ja nicht um private Liebesbeteuerungen oder ging's nicht um Telefonsex?
Also äh Liebesbeteuerung und Selbstbefriedigungshandlung war der offizielle Verlautbarung. Ich denke, dass das wahrscheinlich äh Telefonsex ist, wenn man sagt.
Ich liebe dich und sich dabei selbst befriedigt so ungefähr stelle ich mir den Telefonsex vor.
Telefonsex, wo man sich Liebe, Liebesbetreuung rüberschickt, ist mir was Neues.
Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht haben die sich auch gegenseitig beschimpft.
Äh okay, was der Geier ist heute schon als Liebesbetäubung, gilt.
Und genau um sowas zu vermeiden, damit nämlich nicht zwei zwei Vögel, wie wir beide uns dann darüber Gedanken machen. Äh soll ja, soll ja eigentlich sowas genau nicht geschehen, dass sowas dann mit aufgezeichnet wird,
Digitas wird aber wohl weiter beauftragt.
Und dann ein ein interessantes Detail war, dass ja der AES Schlüssel, also der Verschlüsselungsschlüssel, der beim Staatstrojaner zum Einsatz kommt, eben bei allen Versionen und offensichtlich auch bei allen
Betroffenen der gleiche ist.
Und ähm das war ja einer der großen Kritikpunkte des CCC, weil dadurch, dass der dann eben auch äh veröffentlicht war, es äh oder der extrahiert werden konnte, es eben sehr einfach möglich war, mit,
jetzt auch,
anderen von dem Staatstrianer befallenen Rechnern zu kommunizieren. Sie hatten ja dann dieses Opft ist oder was dieses Tool gebastelt, wo das dann, wo man dann auch tatsächlich andere Staatstrojaner befallene Rechner eben äh,
kontrollieren konnte oder beziehungsweise überwachen konnte. Und äh jetzt wäre natürlich das Schöne wäre natürlich gewesen, wenn digitales jetzt mal hingegangen wäre und dafür gesorgt hätte, dass dieser Schlüssel,
sich ändert. Und zwar nicht nur von Softwareversion zu Softwareversion, sondern auch von betroffenem Rechen,
zu betroffenem Rechner. Äh jetzt hatte dann der äh Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte darum gebeten, doch mal das BKA darum gebeten, doch mal zu prüfen
äh ob die wie dieser Schlüssel denn da lautet und dazu sah sich das BKA nicht in der Lage. Der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte.
Allerdings dann schon. Fand ich ganz spannend.
Mhm. Ja, ich äh bin immer wieder ein bisschen verwirrt. Ähm.
Ob der Bezeichnung dieses äh äh Trojaners, ja, also am Anfang war ja so der Bundestrojaner noch eher so eine nebulöse äh Verdächtigung, ja, dass er den eingesetzt werden könnte, bis er den dann mal wirklich gefunden wurde, dann hat
hatte man ihn dann endlich mal an der Angel, dann hieß er aber dann Staatstrojaner.
Nicht ganz so sicher was die Motivation dahinter war, ihn so zu nennen, aber das erschien mir so, dass man zunächst nur den Verdacht hatte, dass er auf Landesebene, also vom gesamten Staat so in der Summe eingesetzt wird. Jetzt
im Rahmen dieses Berichtes kamen aber doch glaube ich auch noch mit raus, dass er sehr wohl auch auf Bundesebene zum Einsatz kam.
Ja, Bundeskriminalamt, ne?
Genau. Und deshalb will doch wieder ein Bundestrojaner.
Ja also es ist äh also was da was da was da los.
Läuft, man kann nur noch seufzen, meinst du?
Man kann wirklich nur noch seufzen. Also ähm das jetzt nun mal also dieser Bundesdatenschutzbericht ist in in diesem
Zusammenhang sicherlich sehr interessant. Es gab dann auch äh eine äh interessante Einschätzung des CCC äh aus dem jetzt auch die meisten Punkte, die ich jetzt gerade, über die ich gerade so referiert habe, äh zitiert waren.
Ähm es hat da wirklich relativ komisches Ausmaß, äh was da, was da irgendwie gerade.
Passiert mit diesem Staatstrianer. Und damit kommen wir ja eigentlich auch direkt zu unserer nächsten Meldung.
Tim drückt den Themenknopf.
Ja, wir haben ja hier alles äh auch hier wird ordentlich indiziert.
Ja, der denn äh plötzlich tauchte der Bericht des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums auf, beziehungsweise
zwei Berichte des parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums und die haben sich damit auseinandergesetzt, was im Jahr zweitausendzehn an E-Mails und Datenverbindungen überprüft wurde,
Und da stand die interessante Zahl äh ich weiß nur, es ist siebenunddreißig Millionen, den Rest der Stellen, habe ich mir nicht gemerkt. Hast du die, hast du die Zahl noch im Kopf.
Nö, aber ich glaube, die ist auch äh eher irrelevant.
Siebenunddreißig Millionen und ein paar Zerquetschte. Ähm.
E-Mails und Datenverbindungen wurden überprüft und da hat also dann haben diese Behörden offensichtlich eine Liste von sechzehntausendvierhundert Begriffen, die als Anhaltspunkte dienen.
Das sind dann offensichtlich also der Scherz bei Twitter war dann natürlich, dass der Begriff wahrscheinlich Bombe und Terror ist.
Und deswegen jetzt jeder sich Bombe und Terror in seine E-Mail-Signatur schreiben soll, um die zu verwirren, stellt sich aber raus, braucht man gar nicht, weil das größte Problem, was sie mit ihrer E-Mail Überwachung haben, ist äh Spam.
Weil ähm also das Hauptproblem ist Spam, weil sie offensichtlich erstens nicht fit genug sind, Spam ordentlich auszusortieren.
Und äh zweitens, weil im Spam dann eben auch offensichtlich häufiger Begriffe fallen, die äh ein, einen von ihren sechzehntausendvierhundert äh,
Begriffe umfassenden Liste entspringen. Ähm.
Ich hoffe, dass Sexpillen jetzt nicht auch zum Bedrohungsszenario dazugehören, weil das könnte dann die große.
Auch.
Ja, ich kriege so alles Mögliche.
Was mich jetzt äh, ich muss zugeben, ich habe da den Ursprungsbericht nicht äh gesehen. Du sprichst hier von siebenunddreißig Millionen E-Mails und Datenverbindungen. Ist das jetzt und oder Datenverbindungen oder äh sowohl das eine ist auch das andere und in der Summe sind es siebenunddreißig oder jeweils siebenunddreißig und was genau heißt Datenverbindung? Wo wurden diese E-Mails
abgegriffen? Wo wurden diese Datenverbindungen abgegriffen.
Ja und das äh da klicke ich jetzt mal hier nochmal auf diesen Bericht
ähm in wirklich, also es ist im Bericht, wie gesagt, vom parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium müsste man vielleicht nochmal ähm kurz erklären, was das ist. Das parlamentarische Kontrollgrimm ist also so ein Unterausschuss des Bundestages.
Da sind alle Parteien drin vertreten. Ähm.
Wer jetzt im Netz politischen oder grundsätzlich in dem Bereich vielleicht ein bisschen bekannter ist, äh ist wahrscheinlich der ähm,
Herr Altmaier ist da drin, der Peter Altmaier, aber auch der Herr Uhl und äh dann noch der Christian Ströbele,
Ähm unter die sollen also quasi, die sind dafür gedacht, die ähm die Geheimdienste so ein bisschen zu,
überwachen. Also sollen die Geheimdienste gehen, also quasi zum parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium und erzählen ihnen ein bisschen was und die sollen dafür sorgen, dass bei den Geheimdiensten irgendwie alles schön nach äh nach rechten Dingen zugeht.
Wem wir uns der Begriff parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium irgendwie so ein bisschen unbekannt vorkommt, der mag sich vielleicht an die alte Bezeichnung noch erinnern, denn es ist ja früher mal parlamentarische Kontrollkommission, die dann unglücklicherweise mit,
abgekürzt wurde. Das fand man dann irgendwann nicht mehr ganz so angemessen. Und äh
daher diese Umbenennung veranlasst und ähm ja
ich glaube zweitausendneun hat man das dann irgendwie äh äh mal geändert,
übrigens auch noch erwähnenswert in dieser Mitgliederliste, die ist ja gar nicht so lang, ja? Also es sind so die üblichen Verdächtigen, Parteien halt mit drin, äh Wolfgang Neskovic, der auch eher als deutlicher äh Kritiker bekannt ist.
Neben Ströbele äh ist da halt auch noch mit drin. Ja.
Und genau und den die was sie also jetzt wenn man sich diesen Bericht anschaut das sind hier grade mal der umfasst sieben Seiten und die erste ist die Inhaltsangabe ja? Und die letzte ist wahrscheinlich nur die letzte ist leer.
Also ähm ein relativ.
Also insgesamt sechs Seiten. So und da steht dann irgendwie drin, Atmung, um Art und Umfang, ja? Und dann steht da, ja, äh, ist nur berechtigt, wenn man irgendwie Terror und sonst was verfolgt. Und, äh,
Dann steht da ähm allgemein Schätzungen zufolge liegt der Spamanteil im internationalen E-Mail-Aufkommen bei neunzig Prozent. Aber so genau ähm,
eine genaue Aufschlüsselung, wie das jetzt technisch stattgefunden hat, die geben sie nicht, was sie wohl geben, äh ist ein bisschen, äh sagen sie also, es gibt,
zehntausend, nee, zehn Millionen Telekommunikationsverkehre. Davon waren.
Äh einige wenige tausend, weniger aus dem Bereich der E-Mail-Erfassung. Und ähm wie sie aber jetzt an die Daten gekommen sind.
Ähm das wird da gar nicht großartig ausgeführt.
Aber das ist ja jetzt auch nicht, also es wird jetzt nicht sagen, es ist nicht schwierig, da ranzukommen, aber man muss schon mal eigentlich müsste schon mal genau wissen,
worum es sich jetzt hier konkret handelt, also wo kommen die jetzt her, weil E-Mail ist ja nicht unbedingt im eigentlichen Sinne ein zentraler Dienst, sondern da wird
mehr oder weniger direkt verschickt, also wenn ich dir von meinen Mailserver
Wenn ich dir eine Mail schicke und wir haben beide unsere eigenen Mailserver bei irgendeinem Provider, dann geht diese Melde mehr oder weniger direkt. Es
kann auch mal Umleitungen geben, bei nicht verfügbar
keit, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man da so einen zentralen E-Mail-Server hat, wo Bundesrepublik Deutschland draufsteht, mit einem großen Schnorcherhahn, äh äh wo sie dann mal alle mit zuschalten können, sondern ähm man müsste dann schon
Bei besonders bei den üblichen Verdächtigen etwas größeren Aufwand treiben, nicht selten sind diese äh Übertragungsverbindungen auch äh verschlüsselt
ich sage mal jetzt nicht selten, weil es nicht unbedingt die Mehrheit und der Normalfall ist, aber äh zunehmendem Maße und so kann ich eigentlich nur den Verdacht äußern, dass man jetzt hier vielleicht dann doch eher
Bei den großen Providern mal äh abgegriffen hat, frage ich mich auch, auf welcher
Basis funktioniert das hier, also alle Leute, die jetzt zu Web DE gehen, et cetera, also besonders bei zu Deutschen Providern, denke ich, sind da.
Eher äh gefährdet, weil da hat man nun mal so einen Ort, wo gleich ganz viele sind und wenn man da eben mit einer äh mit einem Paragrafen gefüllten Dokument an die Tür klopft, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit schon relativ groß
dass dort äh Daten auch weitergereicht werden, während das eben jetzt so im Individualverkehr nicht so einfach ist.
Ja. Also da da gibt's sicherlich Unterschiede und wahrscheinlich ist äh das äh,
Das Philosophieren darüber äh auch gar nicht äh ungewünscht, dass sie nämlich natürlich jetzt hier keine konkreten Angaben machen. Also hier ist ganz viel mit
Paragraphen und wann darf man das überhaupt und in welchen Zahlen? Und dann kommen am Ende ein paar Zahlen, aber es es steht wirklich nicht dabei, wie sie das gemacht haben, ja? Und die natürlich liegt es, also nicht im Detail. Natürlich liegt es nahe,
äh zu vermuten, dass sie äh einfach Zugriffsmöglichkeiten bei großen Providern haben.
Ja, vor allem die Zahlen, die relativieren sich auch schnell wieder, wenn man mal sieht, was sie da so rausgefiltert haben, ne, also hier ist die Rede von hundertachtzig der erfassten Telekommunikationsverkehre wurden schließlich als nachrichtendienstlich relevant eingestuft. Hierbei handelt es sich um zwölf,
zwölf E-Mail, vierundneunzig Fax und vierundsiebzig Sprachverkehre.
Genau, Fax und so zählt dann auch.
Können sie natürlich ein bisschen einfacher überwachen. Das ist ja ganz interessant, weil das also diese äh hundert, knapp hundertachtzig oder was das waren, das ist also eine relative Häufigkeit von sieben Komma zwei Mal zehn hoch minus sechs
Ja also äh irgendwie null Komma null null null sieben zwei Prozent. Ähm.
Das heißt, man könnte jetzt natürlich sagen, ähm ein bisschen beknackte Maßnahme. Wenn sie, dann kommt aber natürlich dazu, dieses mit dem äh mit dem Spam, ne, wenn sie
da wenn man jetzt berücksichtigt, dass irgendwie neunzig Prozent ohnehin Spam waren, dann äh könnte man sich diese Zahlen ein bisschen schöner rechnen, ja? Also das das diese ähm,
dass dieses Erfassen irgendwie interessanter wäre. Andererseits, wenn sie Spam miterfassen,
dann schnorcheln sie ja offensichtlich nicht am SMTP Server, sondern am E-Mail-Eingang.
Sonst würden sie, ich meine.
Nee, SMTP ist senden und äh iMap oder POP drei ist der Eingang. Also da, wo der sie schnorcheln, das heißt, sie sie lesen.
Eingang ist SMTP, also man sendet dahin, man sendet in den Eingang und äh was du meinst, ist die die Mailbox, nachdem die wenn der wenn der wenn der User seine Mail dann die eingegangene Mail holt, dass,
Würde ich jetzt aber nicht als den Eingang, sondern eher schon als das Vorliegende.
Ah okay, also was ich meine ist, sie lesen was ich was ich meine ist sie lesen offensichtlich nicht was jemand für E-Mails schickt, sondern sie lesen was jemand für E-Mails bekommt.
Weil wenn ein ein Spammer des Weges daherkommt und irgendwie durch die Welt spamt.
Na ja, okay, es sei denn, es ist jetzt ein Wort Netz. Okay, also diese.
Drehen uns da, glaube ich, sehr im, im Kreis. Also je nachdem äh äh als als erstes klingen diese siebenunddreißig Millionen Verkehre
viel, ja, jetzt ist es ein bisschen unklar, wenn man halt wenn man sagt, okay, das ist aber jetzt alles und da gibt's Spam wieder von runter, dann sind die Zahlen, die dabei übrig bleiben, im Vergleich zu der Real versendeten E-Mail ist das irgendwie auch schon wieder nichts. Daraus destillieren sie sich jetzt hier irgendwie zwölf gefährliche E-Mails zusammen. Man kann sich nun wirklich fragen,
was da eigentlich abgeht.
Ähm nur als ans als Hinweis, dass es also zweitausendzehn, ne? Also es äh seitdem sind schon wieder ähm anderthalb Jahre vergangen und im Vergleich zu zweitausendneun ist das schon mal ein mehr als eine Verfünffachung.
Hm, na ja, wahrscheinlich hat sich der E-Mail-Verkehr auch verfünffacht.
Zwischen zweitausendneun und zweitausendzehn.
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall dürfte er nicht geringer geworden sein.
Geringer geworden ist er sicherlich nicht. Was sie weiterhin zum Einsatz gebracht haben, das geht dann aus dem zweiten Bericht hervor ähm sind Insi-Catcher. Ähm,
sind, man könnte es jetzt kurz fassen als Men in the Mittelangriffe auf Mobiltelefone, das sind also Geräte, die der der tatsächlichen Funkzelle meines Providers gegenüber.
Sich so verhalten, als wären sie mein Telefon.
Also ein mobiler Schnorchel für Mobilfunk, um es mal so auszudrücken. Also nichts, was jetzt irgendwie zentral bei irgendwelchen Providern installiert wird, sondern wo man mal so auf der Straße sich zwischenschalten kann. Mhm.
Kann man sich mal auf der Straße zwischenschalten. Die tun also den Provider der Provider Antenne gegenüber so, als wären sie mein Telefon und meinem Telefon gegenüber so, als wären sie der Provider und äh zwingen mich dann offen Verschlüsselungsverfahren oder kein Verschlüsselungsverfahren, sodass sie irgendwie mitschneiden können.
Ähm die kamen.
Zwischen zweitausendzwei und zweitausendzehn insgesamt siebenundneunzig Mal und äh zweitausendzehn sechzehn Mal zum Einsatz.
Fand ich jetzt auch mal ganz äh interessant. Die setzt der Verfassungsschutz ein ähm.
Keine Ahnung, wen sie damit überwacht haben, auf jeden Fall offensichtlich nicht den äh Nationalsozialistischen Untergrund, aber ähm.
Kommen auch zum Einsatz. Äh fand ich immer so eine fand ich immer so eine interessante Sache ähm im See Catchers,
ja, ist irgendwie so eine, man man denkt eigentlich nicht, dass staatliche Behörden äh staatliche, vernünftige, sage ich mal, äh
irgendwie etablierte Behörden solche Geräte tatsächlich nutzen müssen, weil sie eben ja auch einfach bei den Providern anfragen könnten. Äh insofern,
wird so was eigentlich eher in, sage ich mal, in Shady-Bereichen genutzt oder es wird vermutet, dass vielleicht im im Bereich der,
Botschaften in Berlin, vielleicht der ein oder andere im Seecatcher stehen könnte oder so. Das sind aber dann eher so Verschwörungstheorie. Nur das wäre eben so ein, so ein Anwendungsfall, wo man mal einen nutzen würde.
Wenn ich jetzt davon ausgehen der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, wenn nicht natürlich hat da, bietet da jeder Provider die Möglichkeit, ja wir hatten das ja besprochen mit den stillen SMS und mit den.
Den Gesprächsverbindungen, die man sich da im Zweifelsfall einfach abholen kann. Das heißt, ich brauche eigentlich nicht unbedingt einen.
Das ist im eigentlichen Sinne geheimdienstliche Aktivität, ja, was ich äh hinter den Kulissen des Gesetzes abspielt und was sich wahrscheinlich deswegen auch weitgehend der Kontrolle.
Brauche ich dann, wenn ich keinen äh Richter äh Beschluss habe oder haben kann, weil ich nämlich irgendwie ja.
Oder haben will.
Oder haben will, genommen. Ja, komme also auch zum Einsatz. Gibt es ein interessantes Projekt, was beim,
ähm Chaos Communication Kongress vorgestellt wurde, nämlich den Catcher Ketchup, ein,
im Sequetcher Detector für OSMO Kombi, äh den ich hier an der Stelle mal empfehlen wollte, ist ein ganz interessantes Softwareprojekt, ähm wo ich aber auch als Disclaimer sagen muss, dass derjenige, der das entwickelt hat, ein Arbeitskollege von mir ist.
Gut, haben wir das Thema durch. Wir müssen, glaube.
Ja in die Links, in die Linksammlung habe ich natürlich dann auch noch die klassischen, ja, wie verschlüsselt man seine E-Mails, wie verschlüsselt man seine Messages? Äh,
links gemacht, so dass wer jetzt also weiter äh über Bomben und sowas schreiben möchte äh oder irgendwie mal gucken möchte,
sich darüber Gedanken macht, dass er sich halt einfach mal informieren kann, wie man seine E-Mails verschlüsselt. Wie es nämlich wahrscheinlich jeder andere Terrorist auf dieser Welt auch macht
niemals von diesem Quatsch irgendwann jemals äh betroffen wird. Wobei ich sagen muss, äh bevor ich jetzt hier wie diese Terrorismuskeule irgendwie noch äh,
betone, äh es ging hauptsächlich um Waffenhandel, also dreizehntausend dieser,
sechzehn Komma viertausend Begriffe betreffenden Waffenhandel und ähm fünfundzwanzig,
Millionen der siebenunddreißig Millionen Daten und sonst was Verbindungen, betreffen auch den Waffenhandel. Also es geht hauptsächlich um.
Illegalen Waffenhandel offensichtlich. Was einen ja dann auch überrascht.
Hm. Warum überrascht dich das?
Weil ich seit ich noch nie irgendwo eine illegale Waffe äh gesehen habe.
Ja gut, das heißt ja nix. Also das die gibt es ja.
Vielleicht will ich auch eine haben. Nein. Also ich äh ich ich halte Deutschland für einen für einen irgendwie relativ waffenarmes Land und äh wenn ich jetzt höre, dass hier die illegale Waffen handelt, okay, das kann natürlich auch nochmal.
Ich würde aber nicht sagen, dass Deutschland äh einen Waffenhandel armes Land ist. Das kann man nun von äh äh Deutschland nicht unbedingt behaupten.
Nee, nee, im im Export sind wir da natürlich äh weltweit äh an an besonderer Position. Wahrscheinlich geht's da auch nicht um die äh um die Waffen, die man die jetzt, die ich mir leisten könnte.
Dass äh illegaler Waffenhandel ein Problem ist, dass da sind wir uns ja sicherlich einig. Aber es ist halt sehr schwer, solche.
Solche Aktivitäten, also solche Überwachungsaktivitäten zu beurteilen, wenn man nur so wenig Daten darüber hat. Ich meine, diese Kontroll, dieses Kontrollgremium
darf auch nicht viel erzählen. Man muss sich generell darauf,
verlassen, dass die schon irgendwas vielleicht auch bewirken, wenn man sich so die Äußerungen unter anderem von Ströble so äh so gibt, welche welche Einflussmöglichkeiten es dort gibt
da hat man dann doch eher seine Zweifel. Ich meine, die unterliegen dann genauso dieses äh dieser Geheimnisvereinbarung. Von daher ist diese ganze Kontrolle
im Prinzip auch für die Katz, ja, ich meine, was hat man davon, dass da äh,
Parlament kontrolliert, aber dann auch nichts darüber sagen darf, da muss man sich dann eben nur auf den Konsens, äh der dort gebildet wird, einlassen. Der ist im Wesentlichen
von den Mehrheiten des Bundestages geprägt
und ähm man hat da so Äußerungen im Sinne von, na ja, wie das da läuft, ist ja alles nicht so toll und die andere Seite meint, na ja, nee, das ist schon alles ganz in Ordnung. Und das war's dann eigentlich mit der Kontrolle.
Ja.
Der Wolfgang Neskovic, den du bereits erwähnt hast, bezeichnet dieses Kontrollgremium als zahnlosen Wachhund, äh der die Geheimdienste kontrollieren soll, aber nicht kontrollieren kann. Da gibt's eine, unter ich glaube, von Ströbele hört man
ähnliche ähm Einschätzungen jedes Mal, wenn er dazu befragt wird, gibt's auch eine Folge des Küchenradios.
Wolfgang Leskovic, ne?
Mit Wolfgang Neskovic, ja die verlinken wir auch mal noch. Ja, das.
Zu empfehlen.
Das war sehr interessant. Von zweitausendsieben ist die oje. Ähm genau, also so viel zum parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium.
Jetzt werden wir eigentlich mit unseren Themen schon durch, wenn äh es heute Nacht nicht nochmal so äh ein Release gegeben hätte.
Ein Release, ja. Endlich wieder lecker Leaks hier für für uns, ja, gibt's wieder Daten, für die für für uns. Und was was ist diesmal? E-Mails von Stratfort.
Ja, das Draht vor war ja vor einiger Zeit schon im Gespräch, da gab es diesen ähm Hackerangriff, den sogenannten von Annonimus, wo die doch wohl relativ wackelige äh Webi-Infrastruktur von Strator,
angegriffen wurdest, trat vor, ist so ein Informationsdienst, der,
per E-Mail und über Ihre Webseite ähm ja Informationen, Hintergründe zum weltpolitischen Geschehen und der Sicherheitslage äh äußert. Der Wert dieser Informationen ist.
Je nachdem, wie man so fragt, mindestens aber umstritten, äh wertvoll. Ähm für jemanden, der sich ausschließlich nur aus der Tageszeitung informiert.
Sind da schon Einblicke, die man so normalerweise nicht hat. Die haben ja auch so einen kleinen Podcast.
Ähm den ich mal eine Weile lang mitverfolgt habe. Das ist schon mal ganz interessant. Da kriegt man einen ganz anderen Blick da drauf, wie so die ganze äh Sicherheitskonstellation ähm weltweit zusammenhängt. Wer dann überall überhaupt noch äh noch mitredet
würde sagen, so als als Einstieg in wie komplex ist die Welt? Hat das immer ganz gut getaucht. Ich war jetzt kein äh Abonnent.
Andere Freunde von mir schon, zumindest wo von diesen normalen Dienstleistungen, wo man jetzt nicht sinnlos viel Geld bezahlen muss
Ja, dann hat dieser Hack halt ähm
zu Tage gebracht, dass die äh Kundendatenbank da doch sehr schlecht gesichert war, ne, also unverschlüsselte Passwörter, et cetera
Kreditkarteninformationen wurden dort ausgeliefert was dann zu umfangreichen Sperrungen geführt hat. Jetzt macht es so den Eindruck als ob
dieser oder doch zumindest ein damit in Zusammenhang stehender Hack auch.
Äh an die Mail Datenbank von Stratfo geraten ist, die nun angeblich Wiki Leaks vorliegt, in einer Masse von, was war jetzt die Zahl? Fünf Millionen E-Mails oder so?
Immer noch weniger als hier unser Geheimdienst.
Aber wahrscheinlich jetzt auch ohne Spam.
Aber weiß man nicht, weil veröffentlicht wurden halt mal wieder nur
ähm ja so eine Hymne homöopathische Dosis von hundertfünfzig E-Mails, die man sich jetzt anschauen darf
das kam jetzt zur Drucklegung dieses Podcasts etwas ungünstig, heute ist der siebenundzwanzigste Februar, heute Nacht kam das irgendwie raus oder heute Morgen.
Und es lässt sich von daher jetzt äh aus unserer Perspektive noch sehr schlecht einschätzen, was da nun wirklich dran ist, aber da wird der Verschwörungstopf auf jeden Fall schön weit aufgemacht. Ähm zitiert wurden unter anderem E-Mails
von äh äh es geht hier konkret eben auch um den E-Mail-Verkehr von
Mitarbeitern beziehungsweise Chefs und äh es wird die These in den Raum gestellt, das Draht vor hier sehr mit den amerikanischen Sicherheitsbehörden zusammenarbeitet an,
verschwörerischen Winkelzügen. Sage ich jetzt mal, so ganz salopp. Was hast du bisher rauslesen können aus der Nachrichtenlage?
Ich habe das auch äh so herausgelesen, wie du das gerade schön zusammengefasst hast. Ähm.
Frage mich aber, wie viele am Ende dann tatsächlich dran ist. Also der der ist der eigentliche Strat for Hack ist ja schon sehr lange oder was heißt, sehr lange, schon einige Zeit her, der muss ungefähr so zu Zeiten des.
Kongress gewesen sein. Mhm.
Ähm also Ende Dezember und dann gab es ja einige Leute, die auch das, vielleicht kannst du mir das noch ein bisschen genauer erklären. Die sagten, dass ihr's überhaupt gar nicht gut finden. Das trat vor eben nicht die Bösen wären.
Und dann sind.
Wer hat das nicht gut gefunden?
Weiß ich nicht, aber es gab also es kann ich äh kann ich zumindest nicht zitieren, aber es gab ja einige Leute, die dann diese der Ansicht waren, dass jetzt also Strat vorzuhacken nicht unbedingt äh so toll wäre, äh.
Ja ja, es gab so die Einschätzung, dass es sich bei Strato doch eher so im zahnlosen Nachrichtentiger handelt, der jetzt äh für Insider nicht wirklich äh tief blicken lässt.
Keine Ahnung, ja, äh diese Einschätzung kenne ich, das mag.
Auf Basis dieser dieser abonnierbaren Daten ja auch durchaus der Fall sein. Nichtsdestotrotz müssen auch diese Informationen alle irgendwie mal
Gewonnen worden sein, dass äh es sich bei Strator also schon um ein weltumspannendes Netzwerk von Informationszuträgern handelt. Das steht, glaube ich, vollkommen außer Frage
was
man sich dann eben fragen muss, ist, wie viel Prozent dieser Informationen, die sie erhalten, fließen tatsächlich in diese öffentliche Nachrichtenkommunikation für Kunden und wie viel ist tatsächlich,
ähm ja, weiß ich nicht, wird da von abgeschieden in andere Kanäle. Das ist,
äh da kann man jetzt hier schön rumspekulieren, man kann sich natürlich dann auch gleich äh mit gesteigertem Blutdruck dann wieder auf irgendeine Annomimuswelle äh bewegen, die wahrscheinlich jetzt schon wieder dabei sind, alles Mögliche äh zu dedossen und äh
zu, was weiß ich, zu proklamieren und Verschwörungstheorien aufzumachen. Das wird uns äh nicht sehr viel weiterbringen.
Von daher frage ich mich eben auch, wie wird es jetzt Wiki-Leaks wieder,
weiterbringen. Offensichtlich haben sie aber ihre Allianzen jetzt doch wieder ganz neu aufgestellt. Auf der WikiLeaks Seite, wo dieses League bekannt gegeben wird, da äh prangen einige äh illustre,
ähm.
Medienpartner, unter anderem auch solche äh äh Gruppen wie wohl offensichtlich auch äh beobachtet worden sind oder da zumindest im,
Mittelpunkt der Aktivitäten standen, weil sie ja wie vielleicht bekannt ist, das sind
sind eigentlich super Hacker äh äh die Jungs, die sich immer mal wieder so auf öffentliche Veranstaltungen einschleichen, äh sich ausgeben, irgend äh einer äh Government-Organisation anzugehören und dann äh absurde,
höchsten,
Vorträge halten und das Ganze dann wunderbar ins Lächerliche ziehen, beziehungsweise sicherlich bekannteste Hack, den sie mal losgetreten haben, war als sie es tatsächlich geschafft haben, bei kurz überlegen. Ich glaube, das war BB.
Genau, also sich BBC anzudienen, äh äh zum Jubiläum dieses äh Chemie-Desasters, dieser Chemiekatastrophe
da dort in die Medien zu kommen als offizieller Vertreter und anzukündigen, sie hätten jetzt also ihren Kurs gewechselt und würden jetzt alle entschädigen et cetera und wir würden ja unsere Schuld vollkommen eingestehen
ging halt alles komplett und er, bevor irgendjemand mal begriffen hat, dass es sich hierbei nicht wirklich um einen Vertreter von äh Dow Chemike handelte.
Das ging, das war live und äh es ging dann, glaube ich, erstmal alle Leute auf den in den Straßen tanzen, bis dann der echte Sprecher von Dow Chemikal, nämlich vor die Massen treten musste und sagen musste, so äh nee.
Wir sind immer noch böse.
Wir sind immer noch böse. Also da sorry, Edge.
Ja, aber er war ein super Hack. Ich hatte auch mal die Gelegenheit, die Jessmann mal persönlich kennenzulernen, muss sagen, es sind ganz beeindruckende äh äh Leute, die also wirklich das Herz am richtigen Fleck haben.
Na ja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall auch ihr Name taucht ihr jetzt hier auf. Mir ist nicht so ganz klar, wie WikiLeaks gerade eigentlich wirklich äh funktioniert. Das scheint mir hier auf jeden Fall auch wieder so eine direkte Zuspielung gewesen zu sein als
Webseite in dem Sinne drehen sie eigentlich gar nicht in Erscheinung, zumindest gibt es jetzt kein funktionierende Upload-Funktionalität, wo man irgendwas hineinwerfen,
könnte, ob's denn derzeit überhaupt irgendjemand wollen würde, weiß ich auch nicht, also zumindest nicht, wenn man selbst unter Umständen direkt davon betroffen ist.
Wie man das ja normalerweise so bei Whistleblowern so kennt und vermutet. Hier kann es durchaus sein, dass es sich eben um ein Abfallprodukt dieses Hax handelte, immerhin
die ganze Webinfrastruktur dort aufgemacht. Da braucht ihr jetzt nicht viel Fantasie, um zu sehen, okay, alles klar, wenn man schon so weit war, kann es durchaus sein, dass man eben auch auf dem Melzer kam, da mal flixen äh äh Backup gezogen hat und dieses Backup,
jetzt vielleicht.
Vermutungen dann auch relativ schnell äh bei WikiLeaks abgelegt, wo sich jetzt irgendjemand damit beschäftigt hat, da mal ein paar Mails durchzulesen. Fünf Millionen Mails, stimmt die Zahl? Ich weiß nicht, ich hab's jetzt gerade so.
Mein schon, aber bis jetzt.
Ist eine Menge Holz, das muss auch erstmal wieder alles gelesen werden und tja, keine Ahnung. Wir können an dieser Stelle nur raten.
Also selber äh bezeichnet sich ja als ein
Verlag, der Nachrichten schreibt, weil basierend auf nachrichtendienstlichen, weniger auf journalistischen Methoden, wir haben Leute vor Ort, die Informationen sammeln, Analysen liefern, verstehen und an Autoren weiterleiten, das ist so das, das Selbstverständnis
sehen sich nicht als Berater, sie würden zwar auch für Unternehmen Aufklärung vornehmen, die seit langer Zeit zu ihren Kunden zählen aber neunzig Prozent des Umsatzes
käme, aus dem Geschäft mit Veröffentlichung und dem hält äh Wiki Leaks jetzt entgegen, dass sie äh.
Vertrauliche Geheimdienstliche,
für große Firmen wie Dow, Chemike, Lokit Marten, äh und irgendwelche ähm,
anbieten.
Und auch für irgendwie US Homeland of homeland Security, die US Mireens und für wen ich alles arbeiten würden. Und ähm ich denke jetzt,
kann man einfach nur mal sagen, bin ich mal gespannt, was jetzt aus diesen Leaks dann irgendwie noch ähm,
hervorkommen soll. Ich meine, wenn sie für für arbeiten, dann wundert's mich nicht, dass sie auch mal einen Blick auf die Jessmen geworfen haben.
Nee. Was was, glaube ich, an dieser Stelle auch wirklich ähm sehr viel wahrscheinlicher ist, also der Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung
na ja, der äh erscheint mir nicht ganz zufällig zu sein äh in diesen, es sind so hundertsiebzig E-Mails, äh Heise spricht von hundertsiebzig E-Mails, sind eben auch E-Mails dabei, wo es eben ganz konkret um Julian Assange geht,
vermute mal, hier soll eben der Eindruck äh weiter unterfüttert werden. Das äh ähm die USA halt ganz kräftig daran versuchen zu drehen, äh ihn in seine Hände zu bekommen.
Es steht ja noch aus.
Damit gerechne.
Entscheidung des in den in Großbritannien ja ob er denn nun wirklich ausgeliefert werden soll wo ja das,
immer so im Raum steht, diese Behauptung, ja, dass äh die USA ja hinter ihm her sind, was sicherlich nicht vorkommt, von der Hand zu weisen ist, ne? Aber was ja auch als Argument da ähm mitdiskutiert wurde, auch wenn's jetzt bei der
finalen Entscheidungen ja eigentlich mehr so nur noch um Formsachen geht. Ich denke, das spielt hier alles mit rein.
So oder so muss man sich halt jetzt fragen, inwiefern solche Unternehmen tatsächlich hier einen Teil des gesamten der gesamten Geheimdienstverpflichtung real darstellen.
Ich wage jetzt hier mal keine definierte Meinung zu äußern, weil da habe ich jetzt gerade keine zu.
Ich denke auch, wir werden das äh erleben.
Genau, laufen und in Farbe im Internet, wie immer. Und dann, wenn die anderen sich eine Meinung gebildet haben, dann kommentieren wir das mal wieder ganz.
Dann sagen wir morgen, dass alles Unsinn ist.
Genau. Und wir haben's ja gleich geahnt, aber.
Er war nicht autorisiert, der uns dazu zu äußern. Nein, wir halten uns hier unaufgeregt zurück, wie immer, bei Logbuch äh äh Netzpolitik. Sind wir denn jetzt hier äh durch mit unserem Reigen.
Ich denke ja.
Gut, Linus, dann äh solltest du dich auch mal wieder entspannt zurücklehnen und ein bisschen Kraft tanken auf das wir eine Chance haben, auch äh in der nächsten Woche wieder frisch einzusteigen.
Letzten Endes möchten wir natürlich hier gern unseren Wochenrhythmus beibehalten, aber in dem Moment, wo Krankheit und äh andere Birnen hier eine Rolle spielen, dann äh.
Müssen wir uns halt auch ab und zu mal ein bisschen entschuldigen und austreten aus dem Zeitplan. Ne? Gut. Dann sage ich mal tschüss.
Ich auch und bis äh in einer Woche hoffentlich. Tschau, tschau.
Genau, tschau.